This introduces us to the need for
parcel order planning.
Parcel order planning occurs
with the multiple goals.
And the plan for
achieving one goal provost another goal.
David, can you think of an example
of parcel order planning?
>> So actually I do have a kind of
funny example of parcel order planning.
Not long ago, we bought a couch.
And to keep things simple, we decided to
pay them to assemble the couch for us.
Then we got the couch home and found
out that once the couch was already
assembled, it would not fit
through the apartment door.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So we had to completely disassemble
the couch, move the pieces in one by
one, and then reassemble the couch.
So the plan for
assembling the couch clobbered the goal
of getting the couch into the apartment.
>> Good example.
Next we will discuss how
partial order planning
can help us detect conflicts
like this and avoid them.